>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ANNOUNCE THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL COUNSEL
IN CONNECTION WITH TWO ONGOING
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS THAT
HAVE RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
ATTENTION.
THE FIRST, AS DESCRIBED IN COURT
FILINGS IN THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA, IS THE INVESTIGATION
INTO WHETHER ANY PERSON OR
ENTITY UNLAWFULFULLY INTERFERED
WITH THE TRANSFER OF POWER
FOLLOWING THE 2020 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION OR THE CERTIFICATION OF
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE VOTE HELD
ON OR ABOUT JANUARY 6, 2021.
THE SECOND IS THE ONGOING
INVESTIGATION INVOLVING
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AND OTHER
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS AS WELL AS
THE POSSIBLE OBSTRUCTION OF THAT
INVESTIGATION, REFERENCED AND
DESCRIBED IN COURT FILINGS IN A
PENDING MANNER IN THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF FLORIDA.
I'M JOINED TODAY BY DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL LISA MONACO,
U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE DISTRICT
OF COLUMBIA, MATTHEW GRAVES, AND
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR
THE CRIMINAL DIVISION.
MATTHEW OLSON COULD NOT BE HERE.
HE IS CURRENTLY IN GERMANY
REPRESENTING THE DEPARTMENT AT
THE G7 HOME AFFAIRS AND SECURITY
MINISTERIAL.
U.S. ATTORNEY GRAVES HAS BEEN
ABLY LEADING THE INVESTIGATIONS
INTO THE EVENTS LEADING UP TO
AND ON JANUARY 6.
HE AND DOZENS OF ASSISTANT U.S.
ATTORNEYS AND OTHER PROSECUTORS
HAVE TAKEN ON THE MONUMENTAL
TASK OF CONDUCTING OVER 900
PROSECUTIONS IN DEFENSE OF OUR
DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS.
CRIMINAL DIVISION PROSECUTORS
UNDER THE ABLE LEADERSHIP OF
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL --
HAVE PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE
IN THOSE PROSECUTIONS.
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL OLSON
HAS BEEN ABLY LEADING THE
INVESTIGATION.
ALL OF THE CAREER PROSECUTORS
ASSIGNED TO THESE MATTERS ARE
CONDUCTING THEIR WORK IN THE
BEST TRADITIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
I ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
EFFORTS OF THE MANY FBI AGENTS
AND OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL WHO ARE ASSIGNED TO
THESE MATTERS.
THEY ARE WORKING COURAGEOUSLY
AND STEADFASTLY AND ARE SERVING
OUR NATION HONORABLY.
I AM GRATEFUL TO THEM.
WE ALL ARE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
LONG RECOGNIZED THAT IN CERTAIN
EXTRAORDINARY CASES, IT IS IN
THE PUBLIC INTEREST TO APPOINT A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR TO
INDEPENDENTLY MANAGE AN
INVESTIGATION AND PROSECUTION.
BASED ON RECENT DEVELOPMENTS,
INCLUDING THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT HE IS A
CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT IN THE
NEXT ELECTION AND THE SITTING
PRESIDENT'S STATED INTENTION TO
BE A CANDIDATE AS WELL, I HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT IT IS IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST TO APPOINT A
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
SUCH AN APPOINTMENT UNDERSCORES
THE DEPARTMENT'S COMMITMENT TO
BOTH INDEPENDENCE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN PARTICULARLY
SENSITIVE MATTERS.
IT ALSO ALLOWS PROSECUTORS AND
AGENTS TO CONTINUE THEIR WORK
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND TO MAKE
DECISIONS INDISPUTABLY GUIDED
ONLY BY THE FACTS AND THE LAW.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL WILL CONDUCT
PARTS OF THE FIRST INVESTIGATION
I JUST MENTIONED.
THE INVESTIGATION INTO WHETHER
ANY PERSON OR ENTITY UNLAWFULLY
INTERFERED WITH THE TRANSFER OF
POWER FOLLOWING THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION OR WITH
THE CERTIFICATION OF ELECTORAL
COLLEGE VOTE HELD ON OR ABOUT
JANUARY 6.
THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE
PROSECUTIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
PENDING IN THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA OR FUTURE
INVESTIGATIONS AND PROSECUTIONS
OF INDIVIDUALS FOR OFFENSES
COMMITTED WHILE THEY WERE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT ON THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS ON JANUARY 6.
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS AND
PROSECUTIONS WILL REMAIN UNDER
THE AUTHORITY OF THE U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL WILL ALSO
CONDUCT THE INVESTIGATION
INVOLVING CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
AND OTHER PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS
AS WELL AS THE POSSIBLE
OBSTRUCTION OF THAT
INVESTIGATION.
TODAY, I SIGNED AN ORDER
APPOINTING JACK SMITH TO SERVE
AS SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THE ORDER AUTHORIZES HIM TO
CONTINUE THE ONGOING
INVESTIGATION INTO BOTH OF THE
MATTERS THAT I HAVE JUST
DESCRIBED AND TO PROSECUTE ANY
FEDERAL CRIMES THAT MAY ARISE
FROM THOSE INVESTIGATIONS.
MR. SMITH IS A VETERAN CAREER
PROSECUTOR.
HE BEGAN HIS PROSECUTORIAL
CAREER IN 1994 AS AN ASSISTANT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WITH THE NEW
YORK COUNTY D.A.'S OFFICE.
IN 1999, HE BECAME AN ASSISTANT
U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE EASTERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK, WHERE OVER
THE COURSE OF NINE YEARS, HE
PROSECUTED MATTERS RANGING FROM
GANG MURDERS OF POLICE OFFICERS
TO CIVIL RIGHTS VIOLATIONS.
FROM 2008 TO 2010, HE SERVED
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL CRIMINAL
COURT, WHERE HE SUPERVISED WAR
CRIMES INVESTIGATIONS.
IN 2010, MR. SMITH RETURNED TO
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO SERVE
AS CHIEF OF THE PUBLIC INTEGRITY
SEC
SECTION, WHERE HE LEAD A TEAM OF
MORE THAN 30 PROSECUTORS WHO
HANDLED PUBLIC CORRUPTION AND
ELECTION CRIMES CASES ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
IN 2015, HE AGREED TO SERVE AS
THE FIRST ASSISTANT U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR THE MIDDLE DISTRICT
OF TENNESSEE, LATER BECOMING THE
ACTING UNITED STATES ATTORNEY.
MOST RECENTLY, MR. SMITH SERVED
AS CHIEF PROSECUTOR FOR THE
SPECIAL COURT IN THE HAGUE,
CHARGED WITH INVESTIGATING AND
ADJUDICATING WAR CRIMES IN
KOSOVO.
MR. SMITH WILL BEGIN HIS WORK AS
SPECIAL COUNSEL IMMEDIATELY AND
WILL BE RETURNING TO THE UNITED
STATES FROM THE HAGUE.
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER, JACK
SMITH HAS BUILT A REPUTATION AS
AN IMPARTIAL AND DETERMINED
PROSECUTOR, WHO LEADS TEAMS WITH
ENERGY AND FOCUS TO FOLLOW THE
FACTS WHEREVER THEY LEAD.
AS SPECIAL COUNSEL, WE WILL
EXERCISE INDEPENDENT
PROSECUTORIAL JUDGMENT TO DECIDE
WHETHER CHARGES SHOULD BE
BROUGHT.
ALTHOUGH THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
WILL NOT BE SUBJECT TO THE
DAY-TO-DAY SUPERVISION OF ANY
OFFICIAL OF THE DEPARTMENT, HE
MUST COMPLY WITH THE
REGULATIONS, PROCEDURES, AND
POLICIES OF THE DEPARTMENT.
I WILL ENSURE THAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL RECEIVES THE RESOURCES
TO CONDUCT THIS WORK QUICKLY AND
COMPLETELY.
GIVEN THE WORK TO DATE AND
MR. SMITH'S PROSECUTORIAL
EXPERIENCE, I AM CONFIDENT THAT
THIS APPOINTMENT WILL NOT SLOW
THE COMPLETION OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS.
MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE PURSUING
THESE INVESTIGATIONS ARE U
CONDUCTING THEMSELVES IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS OF PROFESSIONALISM.
I COULD NOT BE PROUDER OF THEM.
I STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THE
NORMAL PROCESSES OF THIS
DEPARTMENT CAN HANDLE ALL
INVESTIGATIONS WITH INTEGRITY,
AND I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
APPOINTING A SPECIAL COUNSEL AT
THIS TIME IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
THE EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES
PRESENTED HERE DEMAND IT.
MR. SMITH IS THE RIGHT CHOICE TO
COMPLETE THESE MANNERS IN AN
EVEN HANDED AND URGENT MANNER.
THANK YOU ALL.
>> OKAY.
WE'VE BEEN LISTENING THERE TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TALKING
ABOUT NAMING A SPECIAL COUNSEL
TO INVESTIGATE IN TWO OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO DONALD
TRUMP.
WE JUST LEARNED IT IS JACK
SMITH, WHO HAS A VERY IMPRESSIVE
BIOGRAPHY, EVERYTHING FROM
PROSECUTOR HERE IN THE STATES TO
INVESTIGATING WAR CRIMES AT THE
HAGUE.
>> YEAH, STARTING HIS PUBLIC
SERVICE ALMOST 30 YEARS AGO
WORKING IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN BOTH DEMOCRATIC OR
UNDER DEMOCRATIC AND REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATIONS.
OF COURSE WE'LL LEARN MORE ABOUT
JACK SMITH IN THE COMING HOURS.
LET'S GO BACK NOW TO OUR PANEL.
>> WE HAVE EVAN.
WE HAVE JESSICA SCHNEIDER AND
ELIE HONIG.
ELIE, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> SO, WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
CAREER NON-POLITICAL PROSECUTOR,
JACK SMITH APPEARS TO BE THE
VERY MODEL OF THAT NOTION.
HE HAS WORKED, AS YOU SAID, FOR
DECADES AS A STATE AND FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR AND AS A WAR CRIMES
PROSECUTOR.
THERE'S NO POLITICAL LEANING ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER.
THIS IS REALLY WHAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TYPICALLY -- THE VAST
MAJORITY OF FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ARE.
THEY ARE NOT POLITICAL ACTORS.
THEY ARE NOT POLITICAL
APPOINTEES.
THEY ARE PEOPLE WHO JUST COME IN
AND DO THE JOB AND DO THE WORK.
AND JACK SMITH, BY ALL
APPEARANCES, HAS DONE THAT FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS NOW.
NOW, HE IS GOING TO HAVE THE
FIRST SAY.
HE IS GOING TO HAVE TO GET UP TO
SPEED ON THIS INVESTIGATION.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE HIM SOME
TIME.
BUT IT IS A WELL-DEVELOPED
INVESTIGATION.
HE'S NOT STARTING FROM SQUARE
ONE.
AND HE WILL ULTIMATELY HAVE AT
LEAST THE INITIAL CALL ON, DO WE
INDICT OR DO WE NOT?
HE WILL HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
INDEPENDENCE, SIGNIFICANT
INDEPENDENCE, FROM MERRICK
GARLAND AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, BUT ULTIMATELY
MERRICK GARLAND WILL RETAIN THAT
POWER TO AGREE OR DISAGREE.
IF HE DISAGREES TO OVERRIDE
WHATEVER RECOMMENDATION
MR. SMITH OFFERS UP.
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID
THAT THE EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES DEMANDED THIS, AND
HE SAID THAT HE IDENTIFIED, AS A
CATALYST FOR THIS DECISION, THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OR THE DECLARATION
OF FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP AS A
2024 CANDIDATE AND THE
INCLINATION FROM THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT TO RUN FOR
RE-ELECTION.
YOUR REACTION TO WHAT WE JUST
HEARD FROM AG GARLAND?
>> YOU KNOW, VICTOR, THERE
REALLY ISN'T A ROADMAP FOR A
CIRCUMSTANCE LIKE THIS BECAUSE
OF HOW REMARKABLE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE.
AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL LAID
OUT, YOU HAVE A FORMER PRESIDENT
BEING INVESTIGATED BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
TO DO THIS BY THE BOOK, TO
CONDUCT THESE INVESTIGATIONS IN
A WAY THAT THE TEXTBOOKS WOULD
SAY TO DO IT, YES, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAD TO APPOINT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL HERE.
WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO IS TAKE OUT
EVEN THE APPEARANCE OF
IMPROPRIETY.
LOOK, WE ALL KNOW -- I WASN'T
BORN YESTERDAY.
AND WITHIN HOURS, THE RECORD OF
JACK SMITH IS GOING TO BE PICKED
APART, AND HE WILL PROBABLY BE
SEEN BY SOME OR CRITICIZED BY
SOME AS BEING A PARTISAN
POLITICAL HACK OR TOOL.
WE SAW THIS PLAY OUT WITH ROBERT
MUELLER SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
THE SIMPLE FACT IS REMOVING IT
FROM THE CHAIN OF COMMAND TO
SOME EXTENT, TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, IS VERY VALUABLE.
THE OTHER POINT I WOULD MAKE
HERE, THE ONE PERSON WHO WAS NOT
THERE ON THE STAGE, AND THAT WAS
JACK SMITH.
THAT WAS TO GIVE AT LEAST THE
SENSE OF CLARITY THAT THIS IS A
SEPARATE INDIVIDUAL FROM OUTSIDE
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHO IS
COMING TO TAKE THIS MATTER OVER.
AND IT'S ALMOST THE BEST OF ALL
WORLDS.
AT LEAST IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S PERSPECTIVE,
BECAUSE NUMBER ONE, AS HAS BEEN
SAID, HE GETS ALL OF THE STAFF
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
AND NUMBER TWO, A FUTURE
PRESIDENT CANNOT REALLY FIRE A
SPECIAL COUNSEL EXCEPT SOME
EXTRAORDINARY REASON TO DO SO,
LIKE HE LITERALLY SHOWS UP TO
WORK DRUNK OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL DOESN'T
HAVE THE SAME LATITUDE HE WOULD
WITH A SENIOR POLITICAL
APPOINTEE.
I KNOW THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT CRITICIZE THIS DECISION,
BUT IT HAD TO BE DONE REGARDLESS
OF WHAT THE PRESIDENT'S ACTIONS
WERE PREVIOUSLY.